Ellie has nothing it is an empty vacuous
space to be filled with someone else's
ideas that change all the time and
people's ideas are ephemeral meaning
they're fleeting they go away so it's
like if tomorrow the idea was that fat
people are out because they're in now
but let's say they're out and thin
people are back then everybody in La
would just put thin people in all the
movies yeah I mean they're not doing
this to support the fatty boombatties
what happens is
somebody somewhere knocks on one of
their doors and says it's the season of
the pig
and then they go huh
they don't think too much about it they
don't ask why it's the season of the pig
they just go
I'll go find the pigs
two